you should know this by now i'm a hugger
she-ra season five
i'm really gonna miss this show
and i think it went out pretty dang well
i'm not in a position right now to like
rank the seasons
that's that's a tough go
but whatever they end up being at
the gap between each entry it's really
small
these are all really really good seasons
and this one had
a lot to tie up not necessarily in terms
of
main plot it just had to deal with horde
prime and
to defeat him which you know
spoiler i guess it does
you know that shouldn't count as a
spoiler i mean for god's sake
the theme song screams out we're gonna
win in the end i don't think it's a
surprise that they do
when i say that it has a lot of stuff to
tie up it's got a lot of character stuff
to tie up it's got a lot of dynamics and
relationships and
baggage to address
in some fashion and to tie up as many of
those as it can
there's a lot of it i mean just across
the board
even just you know getting glimmer back
from the situation that she was in at
the end of the previous season
there's baggage to deal with between her
and adora and bow
catra holy crap baggage like you
wouldn't believe scorpio's got baggage
micah has he hasn't met his daughter
yet not as an adult at any rate so you
know
baggage and trapped uh has baggage with
being
reintegrated into the rebellion since
she was with the horde for a while
so yeah adora and
beau may have gone and rescued her but
uh as far as everyone else is concerned
weren't you making bots that were trying
to kill us
like a week ago well not that week ago
because it was
it was a while back she got banished but
you get what i'm saying lots
of things to address lots of things that
shouldn't
be glossed over and thankfully none of
them were
i am going to start getting into what i
would actually consider to be
legitimate spoilers at this point so
consider that your warning it's really
good if you like the show up to this
point i assume you've probably already
finished it people were on my butt
about watching this and like
there were comments on the on the
nitpick rants i did
on uh on pan's labyrinth that went out
yesterday saying
why isn't this a review of she or like
okay look
first off you know i you got to give me
a little bit of time and i understand
everyone else binged it through friday
you know what i was doing on friday and
doing most of this weekend
seeing liz for the first time in two
months
so forgive me if getting to this
took a minor back seat much as i love it
there are other things going on in my
life
anyways let's dig into this
so let's start with horde prime
who i'm not sure i was necessarily
nervous about
but i will say that i didn't know how
effective a
villain he was going to be given that
the villains up to this point
have had a lot of direct connection to
the other characters shadow weaver
obviously had a very direct connection
to characters like adora
and like catra and even hordak the ways
in which he
impacted other characters we saw that
over time and we saw what that was doing
to them and then
later developing the connection with uh
him and
entrapta and also what happened between
him and catro so like
there's still a lot of the weight was in
these established relationships or
relationships that we watch build over
time
so i was quite concerned coming in that
even though we knew who horde prime was
it wasn't like he was
made up out of nowhere or he'd been
alluded to before so he knew his deal
but we had no direct investment in him
so i was concerned that he was not going
to be as effective a villain
no he is what they do is they make up
for
the lack of that initial emotional
direct relationship
hook by just making him
super competent in really
difficult to defeat ways
which that was a good way to go now
hordak had been a competent
villain but his weakness was also very
clear especially as we got to learn more
about him which was
his focus on his desire to open a portal
and get back to horde
prime that did distract him and made him
slightly less effective than he might
otherwise have been in terms of
conquering aetheria
horde prime we basically get him and
it's like
okay there's no evident weakness
here at all not even like
his organization is weak because it's
pretty much all clones of him
who he can take over and control
directly at any given time
and it may not even be possible to
actually
kill him and then later on we find out
about the chips
and that he can take direct control over
things other than
his clones and the scope of what he's
capable of doing
that is the kind of threat that you need
to be bringing if you are not going to
be able to bring a more direct personal
connection with the villain
you need to bring basically a sheer
wall of opposition that's like i don't
see any cracks there that we're going to
be able to exploit
and that's what horde prime was so he
worked quite well for that
and i i'd say he's effective
it's interesting with him also because
i found myself getting
uh a little bit invested in his starting
to realize that he had any degree of
vulnerability because
he's definitely one of those guys who
legitimately thinks i can't lose
but in a way that because of the the
power set and the
resources they gave him in a way that
doesn't read as oh
you're overconfident more in a oh
that would be overconfident otherwise
but i think you've actually earned that
level of confidence
crap so he worked uh he worked pretty
well i'm not gonna say he's like my
favorite villain ever but
definitely assuaged my uh concerns about
him not being
as effective all the core cast
does great now obviously the
heavy focus this season is on
catra and adora and they always get a
pretty good focus but
there have also been times where we had
more explicit focus
on the other characters and while
there's a couple of episodes here and
there that highlight other people
um such as like the infiltration of the
party which is a lot of fun with
perfume and scorpio and mermista and
seahawk
that's really cool also a neat way to to
bring double trouble back into it so
that was cool
and there are little things like that
but for the most part
we are dealing with the core
cast here uh and we get a decent amount
of time with
glimmer and with bow but catcher and
adore really at the heart of this
and that's not really a complaint um
obviously you know scorpio is my
favorite character but
it's clear who the leads had to be in
this and especially like it the focus
narrows all the more
as various heroes start to get chipped
and effectively that moves them to
the other side of the conflict so a lot
of what i'm going to be talking about
from here on out is going to be largely
thematic stuff oh before i forget about
the one thing that i would say
not necessarily as a complaint but i'm
like
i'm not sure why
and that's there's the one episode where
they have to land the ship and they have
to go and get
fuel crystals on this
mostly destroyed planet and they run
into these other
travelers the uh it's what is it
starla tall star jewel star
i think that's it that's them the three
siblings
i'm not sure what purpose they
served really i mean
but it was interesting in terms of being
a deep cut
from you know the original show and the
original characters
but given that they never show up again
i'm not sure what was gained by their
inclusion
um although i will say this
i find this thought amusing and i don't
know if i'm going to make it my head
cannon but
it's a thought that percolate around
with those
star siblings in the original
it's three sisters now it's two sisters
and a brother
part of me wonders if that is a indirect
illusion
to the brother being a trans man
maybe maybe not i would not put it past
this show to do that
it's probably the sort of thing they
could not have gotten away with doing
explicitly
but um yeah i just had that thought
anyways let's dig it a little bit more
into the other character interactions
and actually let's focus this through
the filter of
what i already did a video on redemption
arcs
because there's a number of characters
who get
various degrees of redemption here
first up is entrapta who doesn't
actually need a ton of redemption given
the nature of her as a character there
was never any
malice from her towards the other
princesses when she joined the horde
she just cared more about her research
than about the impact that it had on
other people
which that's a character failing in a
lot of ways but
since there isn't really malice there
from her
there isn't a lot of redemption that she
requires as a character but
they did do i think the wise thing of
taking about an episode or so with other
characters like mermista being like um
why are we trusting her because yeah
like
valid and not having characters just
immediately be trusted because they're
like oh i'm on your side now
is something that this show managed to
do pretty much across the board and i'm
very glad for that because that was the
biggest part of my concern talking
redemption with these various characters
anyways hang on to the big one we'll get
there hold it
um there is hordak
which if i were going to
sort of rate these i would call the most
questionable
redemption because he did the most grand
scale damage of any of the
redeemed characters like some of the
other ones that
i you know entrapped or the ones i am
going to talk about like shadow weaver
and catra
they did a lot of damage but a lot of it
was focused on to specific people
especially with somebody like catcher
she did a lot of direct personal damage
hordak did a big scale
damage so the idea of offering him any
kind of redemption at all
gets a little bit iffy because
yes his the damage that he caused wasn't
as personally directed
as someone like say catra so for an
audience perspective maybe it's easier
to forgive
him but should it be given
what he did and how long he did it
i think if the show was going to offer
him any kind of redemption
they did it the best way that they could
which was to show that his
breaking loose from horde prime was a
very
long gradual thing we get hints at it
about midway through but it takes
the entire rest of the show before that
happens his
actually standing up to prime is
legitimately uh
pretty kick-ass moment and then it helps
that they're primarily offering him
redemption
through the lens and the eyes of a
trapped her who is a character who i
think given
her nature and the way she views things
like morality i legitimately buy that
she'd be forgiving
the show kind of gives a token
acknowledgement to
maybe we shouldn't be okay with this
because mermista has a tossed offline of
uh
we're just gonna let this happen but it
is kind of played as a joke
so i it doesn't personally bother me
but i what i could say is i could see
where people would be made
uncomfortable with hordak getting
redemption getting that
given that he basically received a
personal scale redemption when his
crimes
are global there's a little bit of a
disconnect there
shadow weaver got the redemption through
death
which normally i take issue with in this
case
i think if you're going to try and
redeem shadow weaver at all it has to be
through self-sacrifice and she has to
die
not necessarily in a she is so bad that
there's no other way to redeem her way
not
precisely anyways with her
her the damage that she caused is so
fundamental to who she is as a person
her entire approach to the world
i could never have bought that if she
like
turned fully good and had a selfless
moment that she would ever be able to
retain that not slip back into what she
was i would never be able to trust that
so having her have that moment which i
could believe she could have
once in the moment and have her die
during it
i think for her specifically that was
the only way you were going to be able
to redeem her at all
and taking off the mask giving us a full
look at the face
and having her actually smile that was a
nice touch
i'm still not a huge fan of redemption
through death because
if you're trying to legitimately redeem
a character
death is kind of the easy way out it
lets them just
be good for a moment they don't have to
keep trying to get better
which is what real redemption and
self-improvement is about is
being is not making the right choice
once it's making the right choice time
after time after time
after a long time possibly even a
lifetime of making the wrong choice and
having that be your ingrained thought
mentality so with a character like
shadow weaver
for as much direct personal damage as
she did yeah i think she kind of
she kind of had to die especially given
how late her redemption came which
brings us to catra now i did a whole
video talking about my concerns about
catra
here's the thing that they managed to do
because they didn't do what i said i
thought would be the best
idea they didn't like not even the
specifics even the template of what i
thought would be the best idea they
didn't do it
because i said her basically being back
with adora and everybody else
was not going to work well they kind of
made it work
because they did the one thing it didn't
occur to me that they might
do because i made the assumption
that if there was going to be attempt to
redeem catra that it would come
at the very end of the show a bit like
what they actually did with shadow
weaver
and is part of the reason that shadow
weaver had to die because we're not
going to get time with her after this to
confirm that she is in fact getting
better
catra switches sides on
episode 5 out of 13.
so what that means is they actually
have the time to
show her working
at it which it never occurred to me that
they would do that that they would bring
her back
with adora with and be with the
rebellion
any sooner than towards the very end of
the thing and the fact that they did
that was
brilliant that was the perfect
decision because it meant that they
could do
exactly what i would need but assumed
there wouldn't be
time for but they made time which is
to show that catra has to come to terms
with what she has done
not only to adora but to the rebels
to scorpia to feel the pain of having
caused that damage to apologize
specifically and directly to the people
that she has hurt
and to come at to juncture points
where she can make similar mistakes to
what she has made before
again but she doesn't
and they do all those things because
that's what you need to do
to have a redeemed villain actually work
is you have to show that redemption is
not a
oh i'm on your side now oh okay all is
forgiven it's not as simple as that
people are not going to trust you right
off you need to want to
improve and you are going to have to
make hard choices and either catch
yourself or have your friends
help you when you have the possibility
of making your wrong choices again
in the case of capture doing things like
running away
because she doesn't think
that there's anything for her here
and it's not a running away because i'm
afraid i'll hurt you it's running away
to save her
own sense of self and that has been at
the heart of a lot of her mistakes
she shoved the dora away because
her sense of self felt more
comfortable in the idea that adora
abandoned her
rather than dora mated adora made a
decision
that was hard for her
and that she wants catcher to go with
her it's easier for catcher to make it a
hard line like no you abandoned me
and to then just lean on that so hard
which is what she did
for the four seasons prior
so to break her out of that mindset and
have her come close to slipping to
doing something that would have not
helped anybody accept
her which was what her running away
would have been
to have her be at that juncture and be
pulled back from that decision
with the acknowledgement at every step
this is hard
yes they managed it they pulled it off
is it the most in-depth and like
complete recognition
of all the things that maybe she needs
to go through to get to really
get there i don't know but
for a 13 episode you know 24 minute
episode you know minutes per episode
stint on a
show aimed at kids this is this is good
it made all the right decisions for how
to tackle redeeming characters like this
and also you know all the cuteness like
finding out that
kyle has a crush on regalia and
seeing towards the end it looks like
they're kind of together now and
catcher and adora got to kiss
and that was really nice i know some
people might complain about that
and like because i know that was an
issue with i haven't seen it but i know
it was an issue with something like
legend of korra
that there wasn't an acknowledgement of
that connection between two characters
until the very end
i and that was like a mandate from the
network they wouldn't allow that to be
confirmed until the very last episode
i don't know if it was a mandate in this
case or not but it feels justified
because
the two are on opposite sides of a
conflict it's not like they have a ton
of opportunities
to kiss prior to the point that they do
it felt earned it it worked
pretty much everything about this worked
like tiny
like complaints are tiny the star
siblings
not even bad i'm just like not sure why
uh the redemption of hordak like i said
at the end of the day like i'm okay with
it but i can see where there's like a
little bit of a
not entirely sure but by and large the
choices made
the performances the animation's great
they nailed this and it was nice because
final seasons are hard even if you've
got a plan
final seasons are hard to pull off a
nail
they nailed it with this this is this is
gonna go up there as one of my favorite
now
completed pieces of television
it'll go up there with the max and
galavant
yeah man and the good place
just a really good from start to finish
piece of television i'm so glad i got to
be here for the ride
she-ra season five what do you think
about it whatever your thoughts are
drop something on down in the comments
let's talk about it
usual stuff like subscribe i have a
patreon that is greatly appreciated
um and you know links to other stuff
social media etc but
uh you also don't have to end of the day
you're the council i just run the
meetings and until next time
this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
um
bye